hey guys I'm Dan and I just like to
point out then yesterday I said it was
Wednesday well let me tell you how we
should GameSpot news we actually shoot
the day after the day the GameSpot news
comes out so while I said it was
Wednesday it technically was Wednesday
where we were shooting
however yesterday's episode was Tuesday
therefore today it's Thursday but in
fact this episode is Wednesday well so
I'm back first up there's not a whole
lot of meat to this story to tell you
the truth but we figured you'd want to
know if you like being on the cutting
edge of technology you can sign up for
the most exciting beta running that's
right the PlayStation 5.0 system update
beta that's right if you're at least 18
years of age and have access to a master
account on your ps4 you can sign up to
try out the 5.0 update early beta
registration runs from today until the
beta kicks up in early August according
to a playstation blog post originally
the registration form how to check box
where you needed to indicate that you
are a PlayStation now subscriber it now
has a box where you can indicate that
you are not a subscriber as well that
said it may be that the 5.0 update
features some kind of new now related
functionality but at this stage we can
only speculate on what will be included
to find the signup pages for those of
you in the US and Europe head to our
story on games but as with all system
update betas you will be able to roll
back to the current firmware if you want
to in the immortal words of Staind it's
been a while since we've been able to
tell you how to get your hands on some
free stuff so let's change that all of
Doom's multiplayer DLC is now free
Bethesda and its software are banishing
dooms $40 season past to the depths of
hell that means if you own the game or
pick it up from now on
you'll have access to nine additional
Maps three guns three demons as well as
new armor and equipment for none of your
dollars update 6.66 which is a very
clever number also addresses complaints
about the hack module system which has
been replaced by a new rune system hack
modules were consumable items you could
use for various boosts my contrast rooms
are equippable abilities and perks that
come as part of your loadout multiplayer
progression has also been revamped so
that equipment is now unlocked in a
specific order rather than randomly
you'll also find improvements to the
in-game HUD and existing players will
have the choice to race that bad looks
or retain all the gear they've received
as well as receiving a special
acknowledging their accomplishments
evolved that sounds like something you
might be interested in Durham is holding
a free play event on old platforms which
includes the first two levels of the
campaign full multiplayer and snap map
modes you can jump in on Xbox one and PC
from July 20 and on ps4 from July 27th
finally Bethesda have released a new
trailer for the evil with them too the
game will most likely be close to play
during this year's extra life for your
enjoyment the new trailer for the
continuing Adventures of Sebastian
Castellanos lays out what to expect from
the story and gameplay this time
Sebastian is returning to the stem world
to find and rescue his daughter Lily
stem is falling apart however so it's a
race against time before she's lost
forever you know if you needed something
else to raise your anxiety while playing
obviously they'll be nightmarish
creatures doing their best to stop him
and internal demons attacking his
already fractured psyche but don't fret
you'll be able to keep them at bay the
traditional video game play with weapons
the trailer showcases an arsenal that
includes knives proximity mines and
flammable substances in the environment
but those two have also details The Last
Chance pack which will give you a bunch
of bonuses if you preorder for your $10
deposit you'll get the burst handgun
which is exclusive to the last chance
pack crafting supplies and medical
suppliers the evil within to is due out
on October 13 on ps4 Xbox one and PC
that is everything we have for you today
do let us know what you thought of
today's stories down in that comment box
and we'll see you guys tomorrow morning
or afternoon or whatever you guys watch
hoping is Marc
you